10 Famous Actors Who Were Seriously Injured
On The Set Of Their Movies
On the whole, acting is one of the safest
jobs in the world.
Actors are well looked after, movie sets are
extremely safe places, stunts are generally
performed by doubles who are more suited to
the job and, in the event of an emergency,
there are always medical professionals on
hand to step in.That being said, some actors
have been injured on the sets of their movies.
Whether it's because they're amongst the few
who are brave enough to perform their own
stunts, or simply because they got into some
kind of accident, even the most high-profile
and talented of stars have managed to hurt
themselves during filming.In this video, we'll
run through a list of some great examples.
Here are ten famous actors who were seriously
injured on the set of their movies.
Halle Berry
Halle Berry has suffered several injuries
on various movie sets over the years, most
recently in 2011, when she broke her foot
while filming Cloud Atlas in Mallorca, causing
production to come to a halt for two-and-a-half
weeks.
Although she performed several of her own
stunts on the movie, the break came when she
was simply walking and heard a crack.
The actress also almost choked to death on
a fig while filming Die Another Day, broke
her arm filming a scene with Robert Downey,
Jr. for Gothika, and suffered a head injury
on the set of Catwoman.
Poor Halle!
Jackie Chan
Where do we even begin with this guy?
It would be more difficult to name a movie
set on which Jack Chan hasn't been injured.
The martial arts actor does all of his own
stunts and claims to have broken every single
bone in his body at one time or another.
As a result, he's in constant pain - something
you'd never believe, given his ever-present
smile.
The worst example of an on-set injury was
in 1987's Armour of God, whilst performing
a routine stunt.
Chan leaped onto a tree from a ledge, but
the branch he grabbed snapped, sending him
plummeting to the ground and cracking his
skull - it genuinely almost killed him and
he's been hard of hearing on one side ever
since.
Dylan O'Brien
The production of the third movie in the Maze
Runner series - Maze Runner: The Death Cure
- had to be brought to a long-term halt in
2016 when its lead actor - promising young
Teen Wolf star Dylan O'Brien - was seriously
injured on the set.
O'Brien was in a harness on top of a moving
vehicle on set in Vancouver, Canada, when
he was pulled off unexpectedly and hit by
another vehicle.
His resulting injuries included a concussion,
a facial fracture and lacerations, and the
movie is now expected to be released in February
of 2018 - more than a year later than originally
scheduled.
Michael J. Fox
In 1990's Back to the Future Part III, the
legend that is Michael J. Fox agreed to really
hang from the rope whilst filming the scene
in which Marty McFly is being hanged from
the clock tower in the Old West.
The plan was for the actor to hold the rope
away from his throat with his hand, but at
one point he wasn't holding it at all and
was genuinely being strangled.
The film crew didn't realise this and simply
thought he was acting incredibly well - that
is until he passed out, had to be rescued,
and was left with an incredibly sore neck!
Channing Tatum
Channing Tatum is probably best known for
his performances in the two Magic Mike movies,
but did you also know that, on another movie
set, he once badly burned his... let's call
it has Magic Johnson.
It happened on the set of 2011's The Eagle.
Filming the movie in Scotland was very cold,
so some of the cast members were actually
pouring warm water down their pants to raise
their temperatures - but the guy who brought
the water to Tatum forgot to tell him it was
still boiling.
He poured it over himself and literally scolded
his genitals - to the extent that it burned
away the skin.
Ouch.
Charlize Theron
The beautiful Charlize Theron isn't averse
to performing her own stunts - but doing so
in 2005's Æon Flux led to the actress injuring
herself pretty badly.
She performed a gymnastics-style back handspring
- having previously completed 18 of them in
a row - but slipped and landed on her neck
with all of her weight behind the impact.
She herniated the disk between her third and
fourth vertebraes, causing her to be hospitalised
for five days.
There was also some nerve damage, which left
the entire right side of her body numb.
It could have been alot worse, however, and
we're thankful she's okay!
Tom Hanks
The insanely talented Tom Hanks gave an incredible
performance in 2000's epic survival drama
Cast Away - but he almost died in the process.
After cutting his leg whilst filming on location
in Fiji, Hanks failed to treat the wound and
ended up picking up a staph infection.
A full two weeks later, after the swelling
around the cut had refused to go down, the
actor went to see a doctor - and was told
he was close to death.
How close, exactly?
Well the doctor told him that he was a mere
hour away from suffering from a type of blood
poisoning that would have killed him.
Yikes.
Sylvester Stallone
1985's Rocky IV saw the titular Rocky Balboa
going up against arguably his toughest ever
opponent - Dolph Lundgren's Ivan Drago.
Sylvester Stallone is known for wanting to
make the fight scenes in the Rocky movies
as awesome as possible - and in one scene,
he encouraged Lundgren to really try to knock
him out.
The result wasn't great.
Stallone's blood pressure reached 260 that
night and he was rushed to hospital.
He had been hit so hard in the chest that
his heart had smashed off his rib cage and
began to swell - something that usually only
happens to victims in car crashes.
He spent five days in hospital as a result.
We sure wouldn't want to get into a fight
with Dolph Lundgren!
Brad Pitt
In what must be the most ironic and unbelievable
injury in movie-making history, Brad Pitt
hurt himself quite badly whilst filming 2004's
Troy movie.
He was playing Achilles - the Greek hero whose
only supposed weakness was his Achilles tendon.
So why was it so ironic?
Well, Pitt tore his own left Achilles tendon
whilst filming a fight scene on set, delaying
the movie's production for several months.
It might sound like some kind of silly urban
myth, but the actor himself has confirmed
it, saying "It's a true story.
It's sad, it's stupid, but it's true.
It's so wrong.
It's such a bad headline."
You're not wrong, Brad!
Nicole Kidman
On the set of her 2001 movie Moulin Rouge,
Nicole Kidman fell down a flight of stairs
whilst dancing in high heel shoes at three
o'clock in the morning.
This resulted in her breaking a rib and having
to film certain subsequent scenes whilst sat
in a wheelchair - such as the part where her
character, Satine, says “A real actress”.
Worse still, she rebroke the same rib whilst
trying to squeeze herself into a corset on
the set of the same movie a few weeks later.
As a result of the injury, she lost the lead
role in David Fincher's Panic Room, which
ultimately went to Jodie Foster.
Thanks for watching our list of ten famous
actors who were seriously injured on the set
of their movies.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other actors do you know who were injured
on set?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.